as i think quite a few of you know over
the last several months i've been
experimenting with the wombo ai art
generator
inputting various
text blocks including my name but also
my
dissertation master's thesis and seniors
thesis titles just to see what it would
come up with
across the various
artistic styles as they they call it on
the site that they offer you
and
the previous ones have been quite
interesting
this one
in which i inputted the title of my
master's thesis
husserl's passive synthesis and the
constitution of language
it turned out to be a lot more
homogeneous in look very
texty as we're going to see so i'm going
to walk you through
what we got there are a few interesting
surprises and i would say i'm getting to
learn a bit more about what this
you know i think machine learning is
really a big metaphor there's really no
learning going on there but
what it can turn out for us now i do
want to say something else from the
start a lot of people have been engaging
in commentary about is this really art
and how do we define art i'm not worried
about that so much i'm much more
interested in seeing what kind of images
get generated and what we can say
about those images so i'm not saying
that you know nobody could engage in
that discourse i'm just saying that i'm
much less interested in worrying about
definitions of art and you know is this
the apocalypse or anything like that and
much more interested in the granular
what do i have
in front of me so let's take a look at
the very first one here we have
something that's again very
texty and i'm saying text-e
rather than text like because it's sort
of like
the difference between truthfulness and
truthiness
as you know came out in the early 2000s
you notice as we like look at this it's
not actual
text although it does a good job in
pretending to be like it so as we scroll
down through this you see all sorts of
things that are
pseudo characters as well as a lot of
blurry stuff
as well i think one of the interesting
features about this as you can see as
we're going down as well is the
stripe along the side with the beautiful
blue and orange but there's not much
else to say about this let's look at the
next one
again
very texty a lot more
colorful there's you know some warping
effects going on with this and then
we've got these brilliant folding
colors into it but you know we look
close again and you know the letters
themselves or characters whatever
they're supposed to be
have
color in them and some of them are
bigger and some of them are smaller you
notice that none of them are actual
characters
we do have this beautiful painterly
folding of color strips into it which i
like quite a bit but there's no actual
communication going on there so wombo
seems to be saying let's do something
this is obviously a text let's let's
make this text like here's another one
again where we have a
stripe down the side but this almost
looks like a pen
instead doesn't it and the writing is a
bit
you could say less homogeneous let's
start by looking at the bottom and going
upward now notice the
diversity of characters here it almost
looks like scribbles of some sort and
then we start getting this
stripe up the side and then as we're
going through we see less and less
all the way going to the top the things
get smaller
and there's less on the page and we have
something that looks almost like it
could be a pencil or a paintbrush with a
band around it
in this one the next one we have
something else added to the mix not only
do we have these large blocks of color
which
aren't characters but kind of look like
characters we have things that actually
look like
chinese characters
and
i don't think they are i mean i don't
know enough about
uh chinese characters to be able to say
definitively that these are not
characters corresponding to something
but again i think it's similar to what
goes on with the other characters that
we have there's
a
character-likeness a vera similitude
that's going on here but it's not real
characters of any sort and so a lot of
computing power is being devoted to
this this mock-up you could say and as
we scroll up we see
these interesting blue bands we see
these red blocks and we see the
uh
seeming characters in there but no real
information being provided so what we've
got here is
you know like a
facsimile of a text not an actual text
here's one where we've got a new element
to it something that almost looks like
a hand writing
and again we have lots of you know lines
and blocks of characters and as we look
at this more closely we can see that you
know this is all of course gibberish and
doesn't mean anything and it's
interspersed with lines of just pure
color and then lines of pseudo
characters and as we scroll down
wombo fooled us once again is this a
hand i mean it looks like it could be a
hand puppet but it's not really a hand
in any way and so it's a suggestive
form rather than a depiction of anything
now here this one is really interesting
because if you look at it at this
top level it looks like we might
actually have like baskets of flowers or
you know stars illuminated or you know
this these color areas interspersed uh
between the text and at the bottom
you know they have some promise for
you could say
meaning here's the text itself this this
one is really uh
blurry
uh there's there's really nothing going
on there in in information wise now
let's look at what we've got here so
this is
you know there are some kind of floral
shapes in this one as well as some star
shapes
but it's really just blotches of color
put together in i would say rather
attractive eye-catching ways if we look
at the other one it's even more so
like that a lot more star-like things a
lot more
uh almost like textured paint
coming off a paintbrush
kind of
stylistics but there aren't any any
flowers or anything like that and we
don't actually have any images that we
can
pin meaning to here
this one is a bit more promising
now we finally start to get to things
that really do look like things and
we've got a bunch of different what look
like pages of text with characters on
them very very small
now if we start at the bottom we have
this you know rather beautiful painterly
base and we scroll our way up we have
sort of a stem
and it almost looks like it could be a
habitation or like a tower a lookout
tower
in the middle of text right and we get
to this
kind of skull-like thing which again
looks like it it could be a house it
could be
something suspended
in the air and there's even what look
like could be little people in there but
we we can't really tell and so you know
what to make of this maybe this is a
house and these are characters that are
depicting you know the the sketch or
supplying some information
then we get to something where we now
have something
not human but certainly human-like we
have a face
and
it's
it's over text and the text is part of
the face but we have what look like two
recognizable eyes and beard and hair on
top maybe this is the edmund husserl as
the uh program
thinks about it so let's zoom in on this
and we see this this beautiful
non-text uh going on there as part of it
sort of like the lines on the forehead
and on the cheek and we can see that
there is an eye and then something
that's almost like a non-eye
just in the right place and lots of
swirls of color is this really a face
that's debatable now the next one
i think we have a face here what do you
what do you think would you agree
it certainly looks like one and it kind
of looks like it could be
connected to husserl in some way a
pretty grotesque cultural right and
there's what appear to be maybe a statue
behind and you know a piece of maybe
pottery or an ashtray and in front
there's a little bit of writing none of
that writing actually means anything and
as we zoom in we get closer and closer i
think we have there
something that looks like an eye but
also could be a fly you know somebody
wearing glasses and then we have the
other the side of the face kind of
smushed in with with the colors but i
think that's a recognizable
close enough
face
then
we get something really trippy
what is this it looks like
a street view of a
city and maybe there's
those characters are on a sign hanging
in the air and we have things that look
almost like books or
tablets standing up and so let's take a
look at it from the
uh from the top down so we've got this
you know
interesting
looking kind of like a cityscape with a
lot of maybe fog in there we scroll our
way down we see this
sign perhaps or tablet or something
along those lines and then it fades off
into obscurity along with the base of
those
statues sticks whatever they are
obelisks
now if we look closely at the
what looks like to be a sign
um again we see that there's
other than you know the possibility of
an l and an o there's there's really
nothing there it's just
fake lettering fake characters
and the same thing on on the sides it
looks like it could be you know some
sort of cuneiform or you know some sort
of chinese characters in some parts but
i i don't see anything really
recognizable
there
then we have this trippy one which we'll
end on um
you know looks like a script but it also
sort of looks like
organic forms penetrating into it and
pastelizing it we could say so let's
look carefully at it at the top we have
and it almost looks like a map of you
know an archipelago or a
city's port
and then we have all sorts of
again looking like writing but not
really writing kind of kind of a cool
aesthetic motif we scroll down we see
more and more of it until we start
getting into all these you can't call
them blocks they're more blobs more
rounded figures that are piled into each
other and you see something that almost
looks like a
a finger coming off of a hand but it
isn't right and we get to the bottom of
it and we have you know more and more
writing and um these rounded edges to it
and you know all of this is is quite
interesting because
what do we have in all of this at best a
few
figures
and mostly just
non-writing pretending to be writing
this seems to be wombo's idea
of what
husserole's passive synthesis and the
constitution of language
would mean
you know is this even language this is
not language
this is not language about language this
is just
images
that ape language you could say so there
there is no signification
going on here
in ways that we can we can see there
might be something signified to us
not in denotation but in
connotation with these images and so
once again i think
you know this is quite interesting to
check out i think we can read in
meaning that isn't really there at all
and that's part of the human experience
so
that's that's pretty much what i want to
say about this and i'm curious to see
what other people
make of this new set of
wombo ai art generated
pieces based on the
the name the title of my master's thesis
you